I dunno I dunno Zeus is Deputy
Chairperson of the SPD and Minister for
migration refugees and integration this
puts her at the heart of the debate
about Germany's response to the hundreds
of thousands of newly arrived refugees
mister sirs
I wish you a warm welcome hello and a
warm welcome to our viewers this is the
DW interview and I'm Thomas pond
missives this is a difficult time for
you and indeed for your family your
husband is hamburg's interior minister
Mitchell Norman according to the
center-left daily the suit tortured
Saito
his policies are anti-refugee what's it
like at home these days are you two
still talking to each other just kind of
Albany enough food soon I simply don't
know where they came up with that idea
on the country he's one of Germany's 16
regional interior ministers currently
responsible for accommodating hundreds
of thousands of people every single day
of course not every Minister has
thousands of refugees to take care of
but this is an enormous challenge for
all the interior ministers they have to
make sure everyone has a bed to sleep in
and roof over their heads I can't see
what isn't liberal about that shaft
exactly the reference was to the
impromptu ID controls and raids he
ordered in parts of Hamburg does it
torch at Zeitoun doesn't think that's
exactly liberal are we going to talk
about my husband all the time no let's
talk about you growing numbers of
refugees are coming to Germany hundreds
of thousands of them are already here
there are tent cities across the country
and winter is coming
Marko's we can do it approach reached
the end of the line Anika Ansan NASA
severac Poconos and it's always hard to
predict what will happen I think we've
done an excellent job so far it's a huge
challenge but you're right
it'll be winter soon and tents won't be
adequate but what can we do especially
when thousands more people are already
on their way here
the state has co-opted enormous
storehouses so that the refugees have a
roof over their heads and we have to
make sure things are properly organized
the refugees all need to be registered
so that we know how many are here we
need to guarantee this degree of
organization we feel afflicted by hope
doesn't realize this is the CSU your
government coalition partner has asked
for so-called transit zones at the
German border to deport migrants who
have no chance of gaining asylum the SPD
opposes this plan why each tell me it's
not for the sphere dot yeah I imagine
these zones these huge buildings where
people would go in and never come out if
they have no chance of being allowed to
stay but who decides who has a chance of
staying and who doesn't who has the
right to keep people there whole
families even just don't see the sense
of having huge detention facilities on
our borders when you can't completely
control the border anyway sustained ven
and zones and egrants invitee a garnish
completely barajas the basic question is
do we want to allow the flood of
refugees to continue entering Germany
unchecked or do we want to do something
to stop it SPD chairman Sigma Gabriela
says it can't carry on like this the SPD
faction leader Tomas Vermont agrees
what is the SPD doing to stem the influx
of asylum seekers it's absolutely true
that this can't carry on it's also the
duty of the SPD to say we can't make
unrealistic promises we can't act as
though there's a solution when there
isn't one it's vending I don't lose on
funding the kind concept for least it
looks more realistic can endure gets
knee-deep present here I'm not going to
outline a proposal here and now we have
to see we've introduced border controls
we have sped up the registration process
we have increased the number of people
working on the ground we've changed a
number of laws
the people with the chance of staying
can find a job more quickly in some
cases we've also had to make decisions
that are painful because I do believe
that everyone has the right to an asylum
procedure there are people who come from
safe countries of origin who nonetheless
have political reasons for leaving these
need to be examined that's what a
democratic country does the final
decision cannot be made in a transit
zone there has to be a proper procedure
Dhafir feared me here a forbidden on mr
and organs is it wrong to say that the
images of what was happening in hungary
made Chancellor Merkel open the border
and that now she can't close it because
she doesn't want to see similar images
in Germany I'm not sure if that's right
she says if you want to close the border
we need to be able to live with such
images first attacking asthma supporters
live with me detaining people at the
border for however long has to be in
line with the principles of a democratic
state to me it's not but I'll say it
again
we need a plan that we can all refer to
for the time being we're all just
talking about vague ideas that have been
put forward
I'm nothing substantial no one's
stopping you from putting an idea
forward yeah I don't believe in putting
forward new ideas every day especially
not when the situation is as tense as it
is right now what we need to do is stay
calm and think hard about how to put all
the various ideas together this is no
time for creative ideas interior
minister Thomas de Mesilla and pay to
admire the Chancellor is chief of staff
our center stage in this whole crisis
are you or less so how do you see your
role at the moment not happy off guard
Alistair quartered my job is to
coordinate right now I'm concentrating
more on the voluntary sector because
I've observed that it's completely
without structure I have to be there
when laws are discussed I'm on a
steering committee and as commissioner I
follow what's going on
but I don't have a ministry as such I'm
not the one who drafts laws I'm the one
who goes over the draft laws and makes
notes if I think something needs to be
changed they're actually put forward by
the respective ministers so it's obvious
that they're the ones who have a more
visible profile it's tightened and the
surveys show that the rising refugee
numbers are helping to bolster the
far-right do you understand the growing
concerns about the number of refugees
arriving here that the public is worried
where it all will lead and firstly any
note you want to keep this one Wednesday
uncanny absolute first in of course I
understand these fears Maurice the vast
number of refugees are arriving all at
once I can understand it but it has
nothing to do with megiddo joining the
pegida bandwagon is not an expression of
fear it's a decision to join forces with
the far-right with neo-nazis to march on
the streets with us and that's not
acceptable I believe that we in Germany
have enough other options when it comes
to expressing our fears our concerns
which are also justify no one in this
country needs to join forces with the
far-right and I have no sympathy for
those who do I think that's about more
than just fears and concerns toward a
bizarre Typekit even the Chancellor has
admitted that neither the government in
Berlin nor the regional government has
the situation under control but there
are lots of people who want their
questions to be answered so would you
mind answering the next questions with a
clear yes or no you were democratically
elected do you have a mandate to let in
a finite number of refugees yes or no
that question makes no sense oh my man
it's your elected as a parliamentarian
to make decisions about issues no one is
even aware of at the point when you're
elected
every member of parliament has to reach
their own decisions so you can't just
say is this right or not
what did the people say that would mean
holding a referendum on every issue to
find out dan Kern's II believe a right
to asylum is enshrined in German basic
law and that's our starting premise
you can't ask is this right or not it's
an our basic law if we don't want it to
be we have to decide if we want to
changed if we don't stand by it anymore
but this isn't a question I can answer
your question isn't framed in the right
way you must admit though that things
have changed since the asylum law was
passed yes but it does happen people do
actually demand their basic rights it
just hasn't happened this way before
it's not just people these hundreds of
thousands of people it's a different
situation we have one-percent migrants
this year because of a gigantic refugee
situation this is a significant figure
but we can cope with it I was at vice
versa finish and Aaron Cohen the SPD is
a grassroots party is it the general
public who will ultimately pay the price
for Germany's much-lauded generosity on
the housing market the labor market in
terms of daycare and schools will there
be conflicts about the allocation of
resources just decline Lord for a start
I think the general public is making an
enormous effort there are hundreds of
thousands of people going out and
working with the refugees going into the
accommodation centers offering
assistance and listening to their
stories we've actually surprised
ourselves with the warmth of our
response but we can't treat refugees and
the general public differently if we do
something we do it for everyone everyone
needs to be aware including my party
that we must avoid any incipient rivalry
that would create a rift in society honk
events and chef Andy Schleck en phones
because air shaft we like to wind are
into
with a little game we give you three
incomplete Sciences and would like you
to complete them if I were Germany's
interior minister I would I won't ever
be in teri minister but if you were I
won't be we didn't do it no longer
applies when the schaffen does we can do
it has to remain our goal but we can't
close our eyes to reality and the fact
that too many refugees might overwhelm
us we have to be careful DAF must man I
grew up in Germany with Turkish parents
my most typical German characteristic is
washing my car all the time I don't know
sir thank you very much thank you